foreign
[Music]
the guys that you've coached that have
gone on and got division one
scholarships or you know had successful
college careers and made into the NBA
has there been any surprises or did you
feel like yeah no no they saw that
petition no no they all were surprises
honestly I'd be foolish to say when I
say surprises I knew how hard Josh
played uh how special he was I knew
Sadiq speaking of genetic Lottery came
in here at five foot nine uh ended up
leaving here I think about six seven but
then obviously grew two more inches at
Villanova so I mean obviously but his
work ethic was off the chain yeah
um so but I can't say that I mean I
think that's really hard to see at high
school I don't even know if I want us to
become a program where I know a kid it's
going to be a pro right right as a high
school player I love the development
piece I love over time when people say
man I didn't you know I knew they were
good players but I didn't see that
coming like I actually liked that yeah I
mean I was just talking to you know I
guess now people call him Mamadou
principal Mama do you know for me it was
miss your game yeah you know what I mean
and and he was just saying said you know
he was just so excited that we were
sitting down today you know and he was
like you know you got to ask Eric like
how he does it because you you know he
they keep winning and they keep beating
everybody but they're not you know
they're not you know they're smaller
than people and they're not you know
they don't have the players at the other
you know and um I mean I know I know
you've kind of already gone there but do
do you think that description is right I
mean do you think that description is
right do you feel do you feel like you
guys are
um
do you guys feel like when you're going
in I mean obviously mentally and and
with the training you're not at a
disadvantage right but in the beginning
of the season if you were to look at you
know the teams you coach
um you know compare I mean look like I
said is one of the great basketball
cities in the world absolutely the best
like yeah
how how do you feel like you do and do
you think that assessment's right no I
think the assessment's spot on I think
that uh and like even if it wasn't like
I you know mentally I always told the
guys the other day we are number one
company that operates like a number two
and the day we stop operating like a
number two you know it'll be the ruin of
us so at the end of the day I think the
assessment physically is somewhat right
but at the end of the day we've gotten
to the point now where the Synergy
between work ethic the players and then
my coaching uh that's where we've been
really successful like you know year in
and year out we're like I think even our
peers are starting to like you know
respect us and fear us in a way that
maybe has been different than in the
past yeah that's I mean it's uh it
really is crazy to think about you you
know it's it's surreal it's it's crazy
because you're right I mean I think that
that was a real
that was a real thing I I you know
losing to other teams jerseys yeah you
know like I'll never forget playing
football here and you know having having
the team walk in and just like looking
at guys on my team I remember you know
Dougie Thornell you know snapping on
people because they were like man look
how big those guys are like you can act
like a man you know like what are you
you're like what are you doing man you
know what I mean it was such a hard
thing to build here because it was it
was really I mean it was a culture of
losing honestly you know I mean that's
really and and so to to to to think
about this basketball you know the men
and the women's number one in the
country it's uh unbelievable it's like
Beyond it's beyond staggering I mean
it's it's it's it's truly it truly is
it's incredible it's a credit obviously
tamika's amazing coach but once again is
a credit to I just I got to give the
young people credit like it's I mean we
know we've done it you know you me
Dougie Gareth Natalie like like that's a
hard place up there yeah yeah right it's
a hard place to navigate and do well and
compete with your peers and make it
matter to you and and then still come
down here on these fields in these
courts and try to be excellent you know
I mean so I give the young people a lot
of credit like you said boys girls
you know soccer tennis I mean we just
we've been we're really really good man
so I couldn't be more proud to be an
Alum I always say I get to win twice you
know I win as a coach but I also get to
brag and this emotional bragging as an
alumni what do you what do you think
about kids these days I mean what do you
feel like um the friendships are are as
Rich do you feel like
um their relationships are are as as
um kind of complex and deep as they were
back in the day I think they have more
Mobility now and so therefore that's
twofold it gives them the opportunity
for that to be as Rich to your question
but it also gives them the ability to be
more separate and doing their own thing
everybody has a schedule and everybody's
doing this and so I mean the thought of
like having to do play dates right like
that's just foreign to me right crazy
and uh and having it to be have to be
scheduled yeah
um and so yeah I think there's a sense
of like the world moving so fast even
what they get to read right what they
get like be disengaged you know it's one
of the things that we do on you know
game day you know no phones you know I
want the guys talking to each other you
implement that rule no phones on game
day yeah that's great because if they
don't if you don't then there you know
we're susceptible to it you know I'm in
my phone a lot you know I'm on Twitter
and I'm you know I'm no different you
know I mean so at the end of the day we
all got to take a step back to reinforce
and re-engage in those commitments of
relationships and and having deep you
know friendships but I do think they're
capable but I definitely think is a much
more you know even self-imposed but
they're busier they're definitely more
self-motivated by things that they may
want and so that's why team sports
becomes important because if they didn't
do that then they wouldn't engage at all
yeah I I have a a friend of mine who
coaches modern day football out in
California you know you know another you
know just yeah Powerhouse program and
and you know one thing he talked about
and his his sons was on the team you
know just got a full ride to play a cow
and you know beautiful family but you
know one thing he talked about is you
know when he was growing up in Arkansas
playing High School football like they
hated the people they played again you
know you know I mean I to this day I
mean I'll be straight up like I'll I'll
sit and take a picture with with anybody
I you know I until there's nobody left I
there's no but if I see somebody wearing
a Saint Albans like I'm not gonna take a
picture
like I'm not it's not gonna happen you
know what I mean and like I might if you
take it off but I honestly might not
right you know and I don't really feel
like that way about anybody like I can't
get down with you in school it's still
in you dude you know what I'm saying and
and I just remember I mean there was
real you know there was real kind of
hatred you know what I mean and but but
I also recognize what this coach was
telling me that there's something real
valuable in that because what he said
now he said you know these top athletes
you know in in in the Greater Los
Angeles area they've all been at camps
with each other they all know each other
they're all friends there's no real
rivalry like that right it's everyone's
just kind of like they're on this
journey of trying to get someplace
together and it's like the high school
is just a stop along the way yeah what
do you what do you think about that what
have you seen yeah no I think he's he's
spot on coaching spot on and uh but I
also think there's a one of the phrases
I always use again is uh the truth is in
the middle
um and so there's a sense of like and
why McQueen one of my hated Rivals uh
but I talked to him almost every day now
so we're like frenemies yeah uh we're
much more we've always been friends but
um you know I think there's some value
in what you're saying though I think
that it's important to maintain the
sense of tribalism when it comes to like
your team and your school so I agree
with you when I see kids around here
walking with like another school shirt
on like I make them take it off yeah
right like I don't play that you know I
mean like that gets under my skin to
this day and so I still say the school
down the street like I don't even call
them by their name so uh and when I play
them I want to beat them you know about
50 if I can yeah and then you know shake
their hand after the game but I want to
beat them back you know I want to beat
Murray bad bad you know what I mean so
therefore I still have that sense so I
try to give them you guys do beat them
which is amazing yeah you know what I
mean because that was so hard you know
what I mean because you you had that
feeling and then they come in you know
and just
man I know man like that's what I talked
to uh you know Mike Wood and I real
super close and uh we talked about that
he he in Dax Ross uh we're just saying
man we had some athletes back here and
if if I was you if I was the coach of
our teams you know what that would have
been like so that's that was a big
compliment yeah can you give me an
example just a kid who's been just a
great teammate something that you've
seen somebody do that has put the team
before them something that you really
celebrate or that touched you
um man I've had a few of those kids I
think you know the majority of our kids
are that way I think that's what makes
Sidwell unique but I've had a couple of
captains on this team who barely played
uh but really exhibited like what it
meant to be a selfless leader
you know a selfless teammate who gave up
everything he had every day never
cheated me uh never gave one ounce of a
day off just because he wasn't playing
uh those are the guys I really value and
I celebrate them and I make sure that
the team knows how important they are to
me because those are the guys that make
a team
right it's not just the guys that are
playing yeah you know it's the guys that
make the team or the guys who come every
day to help everybody get better but
also lift the culture up through the
roof yeah you know I mean guys who live
the culture on and off the court you
have to celebrate those guys and those
you want that to be your best player but
certainly it doesn't always happen all
right and so therefore when eating no
matter who it is we always say you're
only as good as the things you emphasize
and so if these core values are
something like if you ran into any of my
players right now they'd be able to tell
you these three things and they'd be
able to tell you what they mean
foreign
[Music]
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones for 15 off I appreciate y'all
[Music]